tja und an dieser stelle grüße ich sehr
herzlich jürgen hardt von der cdu es
außenpolitischer sprecher der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
guten morgen herr hardt herr hardt
lassen sie uns über den g 7 gipfel
sprechen da war ja schon erkennbar dass
es den usa dass präsident biden gelungen
ist eine mehrheit hinter seiner
zukünftigen china strategie zu
versammeln eine mehrheit die einen
härteren kurs gegenüber china auch
gegenüber russland einschlagen will
und es war auch erkennbar dass die
kanzlerin einen schweren start erstand
hatte mit ihrer haltung die eigentlich
nicht mehr der der übrigen g 7
entspricht
warum ist das so die letzte
schlussfolgerung finde ich etwas zu weit
gehend ich glaube dass es ein klares
signal dass die siebte platz ist dass
wir eine gemeinsame china-strategie
anstreben zwischen den g7 aber eben auch
mit der europäischen union und ich
glaube dass wir noch am anfang der
entwicklung dieser strategie stehen fest
steht dass china in den letzten jahren
zunehmend wirtschaftliche und politische
interessen miteinander verknüpft dass
china erheblichen druck ausübt auf
insbesondere kleinere länder zum
beispiel in afrika und dass wir als
freie welt dem etwas entgegensetzen
sollen und ich glaube da gibt es
zwischen der position deutschlands oder
der eu und der position des
amerikanischen präsidenten keinen
grundsätzlichen widerspruch
die frage ist wie man das im einzelnen
ausgestaltet absolut darüber sprechen
wir gleich noch über die ausgestaltung
ich finde schon dass es da einen
unterschied gibt also die anderen g7
großbritannien amerika frankreich aber
auch länder über außerhalb der g7 indien
südkorea australien sind dafür dass man
auch eben nicht nur die
menschenrechtspolitik und handelsrechts
politik der chinesin verankert in dem
abschluss komitee sie wollten sogar auch
sanktionen verankern und angela merkel
hat es in ihrer pressekonferenz ein
bisschen gemäßigter ausgedrückt sagt ja
man will demokratie stärken es gibt
viele plätze in der welt und der
demokratie nicht so gelebt werden kann
wie man sich das vorstellt das ist doch
deine außenpolitik die doch so ein
bisschen indifferent gegenüber china ist
die frage ist was nützt den menschen in
china die gegenwärtige in hongkong oder
weil sie andere einer religion angehören
in china unterdrückt werden wie man
denen am besten helfen kann und ich
glaube dass anders als das mit dem fall
russland ist dass die chinesische
regierung sehr sorgsam darauf achtet
dass ihre wirtschaftlichen beziehungen
zum ausland nicht unter ihrer
innenpolitik bleiben weil sie genau
wissen dass sie ihr wohlstands
versprechen gegenüber der bevölkerung
nicht einhalten können wenn sie nicht
für offenen handeln und mit intensiven
handel mit der übrigen welt dastehen und
dass es genau der hebel bei dem wir
ansetzen können ich glaube dass die
chinesische regierung zu zugeständnissen
bereit es zu vereinbarungen zu
internationalen regeln bereit ist wenn
sie weiß dass sie im gegenzug die sind
offenen welthandel nutzen kann und dass
sie im gegenzug natürlich erwarten muss
das für den fall dass sie bestimmte
regeln nicht einhält wir ganz konkret
unsererseits diese
wirtschaftsbeziehungen in frage stellen
wieso wie sie heute sind
und in diesem mechanismus glaube ich
jetzt über dialog wie möglich anders als
in russland
ok dann lassen sie uns über das sprechen
was auf dem gipfel auf den weg gebracht
wurde zum beispiel ein
infrastrukturprogramm b 3 w bild bag
better world das soll eine antwort auf
die chinesische initiative der neuen
seidenstraße sein zieht deutschland
damit dass projekte neuen seidenstraße
hat sich für manche teilnehmer als große
illusion herausgestellt es sind ja quasi
joint ventures also wirtschaftliche
kooperationsprojekte von chinesischen
staatsunternehmen mit unternehmen in den
jeweiligen ländern aber häufig kommt das
geld wird dieses projekt eben zu 100
prozent aus china und was zunächst sehr
verlockend wirkt stellt sich dann
hinterher als enorme falle heraus war
nämlich plötzlich china durch diese
rolle auch als geldgeber des projektes
im zweifel in der er schaffte benutzt
gesamte projekt kommt und das ist ein
ansatzpunkt wo man zum beispiel
reagieren muss dass man sagen kann wenn
es eine wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
mit bei infrastrukturprojekten mit china
gibt dann muss die finanzierung also
eine andere
ankommen und deswegen ist die g7 gut
beraten ein solches angebot eben auch
für länder zum beispiel lateinamerikas
oder afrikas zur verfügung zu stellen
dass bei entsprechenden
investitionsprojekten die unabhängigkeit
der kleineren partner gewahrt bleibt
china hat sich mit der seitenstraße
initiative sehr weit vorgewagt ich
glaube dass die erwartung auch aus
chinesischer seite bisher nicht erfüllt
wurden und diese lücke kann meines
erachtens zu g7 schon stoßen
ich würde gerne noch über das relativ
schwache ergebnis bei der klimapolitik
der g7 sprechen aber uns läuft ein
bisschen die zeit davon
und heute beginnt der nato gipfel in
brüssel deswegen lassen sie uns darüber
noch sprechen
nato-generalsekretär ian stoltenberg ist
er würde ich sagen auf der
amerikanischen linie er sagte die
chinesin teilen unsere werte nicht und
china und russland wird ein großes thema
sein auf dem nato gipfel heute welche
akzente wird die bundesrepublik setzen
die bundesregierung
ich hoffe dass es uns gelingt klar zu
machen dass wir 100 prozent so latour
verpflichtung stehen da hat es ja in den
letzten jahren durch entsprechende
äußerung auch von mitgliedern der
bundesregierung fragezeichen gegeben ich
finde es gut dass armin laschet
aber auch die cdu csu insgesamt zwei
prozent ziel als ziel für
verteidigungsausgaben weiter hoch hält
und dass wir ganz konkret als
deutschland bereit sind mehr zu tun
allerdings bedeutet das auch dass wir
wieder zurückkehren zu einer gemeinsam
die entwicklung einer gemeinsamen nato
strategie und ich glaube das wird das
große signal des nato gipfels sein dass
der amerikanische präsident engagiert
wir sind wieder da wir sind auch bereit
in der nato zu führen aber wir sind
umgekehrt auch bereit unsere
entscheidung mit den nato partnern
abzustimmen das war ja donald trump
explizit seine botschaft dass er als
amerika alleine voran geht und ich
glaube wir haben genau die gegenteilige
botschaft von joe biden server nach dem
nato gipfel reist joe biden gleich
weiter nach
zum treffen mit dem russischen
präsidenten wladimir putin
die beiden kennen sich noch aus der
administration unter
barack obama was erwarten sie von diesen
treffen der beiden
das treffen könnte auch deshalb eine
besondere bedeutung bekommen weil joe
biden der amerikanische präsident ja
klar macht er spricht mit putin nachdem
er sowohl mit 7 als auch mit nato als
auch mit der spitze der europäischen
union
konferiert hat also die botschaft die
joe biden gegenüber putin überbringt ist
eine botschaft die konsolidiert ist die
abgesprochen und erläutert ist mit den
partnern und das muss putin schon sehr
ernst nehmen ich würde mir zum zweiten
wünschen dass joe biden das
gesprächsangebot an russland erneuert
den nato-russland-rat wieder aufzunehmen
der seit langer zeit jetzt nicht mehr
getagt hat zumindest nicht in großem
format dass man ganz konkret die dinge
die zwischen russland und der nato in
schwierigkeiten uns in schwierigkeiten
führen
offen spricht und dieses
gesprächsangebot das erwarte ich am
mittwoch auch gegenüber putin und dann
muss putin schauen dass er diesen diese
ausgestreckte hand entgegen nimmt
denn ansonsten kommen wir nicht voran in
der politik gegen russland ich sag
herzlichen dank jürgen hardt
außenpolitischer sprecher der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion herzlichen dank auch
wieder sehen